massive protests in new york city
tonight as thousands of workers march
against vaccine mandates the ingram
angle sent a camera down there we're
gonna have footage for you plus biden
putters around a scottish climate
conference and a cultural backlash takes
flight raymond arroyo explains it in
scene and unseen but first
a commonwealth of insight that's the
focus of tonight's angle
few early on gave him much of a chance
but clean-cut family man and american
success story glenn younkin a republican
decided to go all in in the virginia
governor's race
he traveled the entire commonwealth
connecting beyond the base to first-time
voters and those who had voted democrat
last time around who are now having some
buyer's remorse now we're waiting on him
to speak any moment in leesburg virginia
and we'll bring you any breaking news as
it happens
but here he was earlier tonight in
virginia beach
november the 2nd
we as virginians we get to stand up and
make a defining statement about the
future of our commonwealth
a statement that says that we believe
that we will soar the spirit in the air
as virginians coming together not
republicans against democrats but
virginians coming together and defining
our future
virginians rejecting a culture
that tells our children that they have
to shelve their hope
a culture that says that we have to
accept mediocrity this stopped being a
campaign a long time ago this is a
movement led by virginians
and this was terry mcauliffe's closing
argument
fifty percent of the students at
virginia schools k-12 50 are students of
color and yet 80 percent of teachers are
white we all know what we have to do in
a school to make everybody feel
comfortable in school so let's diversify
are you kidding me well that about sums
it up
one guy promoting a positive pro-family
pro-business agenda for virginians of
all races and creeds and the other
playing to the cheap seats on racial
division
it's so revealing and how sad for terry
mcauliffe
no wonder the trend lines show a solid
victory for glen younkin mcauliffe who's
already was governor and an old pal of
bill clinton's
looks kind of like a caught mackerel
gasping for air on a boat deck
the last fox news poll has yanking up
over democrat terry mcauliffe by eight
points 53 to 45.
fox 5 dc has them up by two so does the
trafalgar group
now as someone who's lived on and off in
virginia since about 1987
i will say that i have never felt a
greater sense of urgency here to elect
any gop candidate
suburban moms who usually meet for
coffee at starbucks they're now power
walking to the polls together
40-something-year-old biden voters are
speaking about tomorrow's election in
hushed desperate tones on the sidelines
of their kids peewee football games
and the official state media outlets are
already out spinning up on call of
defeat
well what do they all have in common
zero sense of self-awareness about why
the democrats are floundering
the reason's simple
politicians who use racial victimhood as
a battering ram and who use our children
as guinea pigs for their own radical
agenda
are finding few takers outside the world
of academia and maybe the teachers
unions
first this species claim that ra
critical race theory isn't even a thing
in our public schools
i was had a young ken uh rallied earlier
today larry and every single person i
asked why are you supporting glenn
youngken it was education education
critical race theory i mean this is
first of all critical race theory as we
know isn't taught in virginia schools it
has one of the best school systems
countrywide
apparently msnbc daytime anchors don't
have this thing called google or twitter
where a few days ago our friend chris
ruffo presented documented proof that
crt is most definitely a prominent force
in virginia schools in fact it was done
under mcauliffe's own administration
back in 2015 the virginia department of
education told public schools to embrace
critical race theory in an effort to
re-engineer attitudes and belief
citizens systems
and by the way that's not all in 2019
the state superintendent circulated a
memo to school districts that explicitly
champion crt as an important analytic
tool in the field of education
now as we speak the virginia education
department promotes crt on its website
one page extols the virtues of
anti-racism in education stating
anti-racism requires acknowledging that
racist beliefs and structures are
pervasive in education and then actively
doing work to tear down those beliefs
and structures
and even someone who should know a heck
of a lot better like uva professor larry
sabato
mischaracterizes the views of virginia
parents who've led the revolt against
mcauliffe and the whole anti-racism
curriculum
the operative word is not critical
and it's not theory
it's grace there's a lot of we can call
it white backlash white resistance
whatever you want to call it it has to
do with race it's this generalized
attitude that whites are being put upon
and we've got to do something about it
we being white voters
wait a generalized attitude what
has he not been watching louden county
rapes covered up a victim's father
thrown to the ground and my personal
favorite the diversity and equity
fraudster is trying to end advanced
courses for gifted and talented students
now these are very specific and
legitimate concerns parents have about
the issues that directly affect the
lives of their children
and as far as this being a white thing
since when is quality education a white
thing larry
one of the most outspoken voices against
the far left agenda would beg to differ
i fit into the intersectional world i'm
a muslim i'm an immigrant i'm a mom of
color
i
am a single mom
but yet i deny all of these
you know privileges in the new
paradigm of the oppression matrix
because we're all human beings and
that's what we need to teach our
children
you get it
officially a white thing right well
instead of being stuck on the defensive
glen yonkin has smartly focused his
campaign on bread and butter issues
the issues that transcend party
affiliation
now most parents want the schools they
fund
to work for them
and of course for their children not
against them
democrats misread the results of the
2020 presidential election it's obvious
tonight
bernie sanders did not win the democrat
nomination joe biden did
biden essentially had a mandate to end
covet that's about it
his far left base wanted much more
however
and he was too weak to resist them as we
told you he would be
and so is mcauliffe who mistakenly
thought he could glide the victory on
anti-trump fumes in january 6th
and this is a recipe for failure not
only in politics but in the media as
well
january 6 is their drug of choice and
every day is an overdose
this is so
so encapsulates the whole problem
everyone with a scrap of honor in them
was scared bleepless of getting fired
and replaced by a real coup planner plot
or carry outer the washington dc
intelligence fusion center actually
suggested to area hospitals that they
stock up their blood banks we actually
permitted an insurrection that would
have taken down our democracy why is it
garland screaming about this every
single day why is that the president
screaming about this every single day
there's nothing right now to keep josh
hawley from you know taking the chains
off the back door and let people sneak
in like a high school shooter
i mean this is so pathetic
it's so backward looking
and no one is listening to them probably
got more people watching just them than
they did during the day
now the democrat party under biden has
gone so far left it's left america and
even managed to turn off very blue
elements in very blue northern virginia
think about it
so much of the success of the democrat
party in the past four years was in the
suburban female vote
as usual democrats took them for granted
including terry mcauliffe
somehow they thought they could run to
the left on education on race on taxes
the economy immigration
and still keep a lock on women voters
tomorrow will show you they were very
wrong
the one group that democrats could not
afford to alienate they have succeeded
in alienating
on election night 2020 when so many
people were demoralized and down i
reminded you that the trump policies
worked spectacularly we needed to do
at the time when what we needed to do
was stick with them
i think when we look at florida
and focusing on the gop for a moment uh
martha and brett the the the coalition
that the republicans have been able to
put together in that state
is really something that they should try
to replicate as much as possible going
forward the other story which i think
you're seeing playing out in state after
state tonight is that trump brought more
people into the party and then expanded
the base from those blue-collar workers
on out
yes ron desantis is governing on that
same populist agenda that was so
successful before covet hit during the
trump years
it's a model for the rest of the nation
and glenn yonkin is smart enough to see
this
just like he had to campaign in every
county in virginia republicans in 2024
will have to fight in every state yes
that means a 50 state strategy
the polling is showing us that america
has already had enough
71 say the country's on the wrong track
that's horrible for biden his rcp
average for job approval is just 43
percent and republicans are holding an
18-point lead over democrats on fixing
the economy in the latest nbc news poll
in other words america now sees that if
we go woke
we're going to go broke
today only 40 35 say the economy is
doing well 65 percent say it's doing
poorly
so the lessons from virginia and florida
are clear
trump showed us that pragmatic populist
pro-american worker policies and
education the economy and immigration
work
incredibly well
and these populist policies work
everywhere they're tried
but the democrat socialist approach
fails everywhere it is tried
heck it's been crashing and burning in
urban america for decades
without safety without decent schools
with soaring inflation what do our
citizens have to look forward to
a hellscape i guess
and all these efforts to stir up racial
tensions it's just not working
yeah people are sick of it all right but
it's also wicked and it's evil it's evil
when the lincoln project does it it's
evil when political analysts do it it's
evil when biden does it and when stacey
abrams tries it and when mcauliffe does
it as he did late today
biden's 10 months in office remind us in
stark and painful terms
of democrats failure across the board
this failure continued today in scotland
where climate control freaks who only
fly private lectured the rest of the
world about sacrificing their standard
of living
of course biden falls right in line
leaving us essentially unrepresented
across the atlantic
when they wake biden up to tell him his
friend terry is flaming out in the
commonwealth
will he understand the significance of
it all will he question his decision to
cave to the far left at every turn
i wouldn't count on it
but you will
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else